[Music]
she's a representative of the aircraft
they don't want you flying on their
plane today okay so you're gonna have to
get up they made us wait and wait and
wait yeah that's the way it is but right
now i'm gonna do fine and i will respect
that okay so i'm gonna need you to grab
your bag and just i did not do anything
actually we'll talk about it outside
disruptive besides speak my mind okay i
know i live in america and that's what
fucking america is about no you know
that
you know that
you know that give me another unit on
the
really if plan
weren't ever gonna put your hands on
grab your bag no i woke up
but you don't want to sit here
no one's gonna put your hands on
yourself all right yeah yeah you're
welcome
but i need you to get up
yeah you need me to get up
you may need me to get up but you know
what i feel my need to do as a person
just like jesus motherfucking christ you
need to call me no
no i'm gonna do what i need to do i'm
gonna say when i need you and if you
you're gonna do whatever you feel you
need you to meet right so i'm going to
say what i have meant to say
no to everybody stand up yeah everybody
is you're going to get arrested if you
do not stop i'm ready
you're going to get arrested if you
don't stand up and get off the air
probably already do you want to get
arrested
one more time and then i'm going to have
to put my hands on you okay for what
reason because let me ask you that
you you're
and that's fine that's fine why do you
have a right to put your hands on me
though let's go come on no why do you
have a right to put your hands on me
ma'am what am i doing that makes you
feel like you have a right to put your
hands on me
seriously though can you tell me that
probably can you just help me to
understand as a as a human that is alive
like why do you seriously though
seriously
why can you just tell me that like i'm
actually asking you guys at this point
here's what's happening they're going to
deplane the aircraft i'm going to take
you off there that was already happening
and you're going to jail just so you
know i already have it it won't happen
with me right now but if you're not
going to check
right now they're going to deflate as
soon as they deplane you're going to
jail okay
that's how it's going to work do you
feel that the threatening system that's
the way it is not cool i want to judge
you you want to trust me that's not
healing we're not healing
come on
can i trust you tonight
[Applause]
let's go
listen have i touched you yet i'm trying
to get you off the aircraft that's all
we're trying to do
do a control situation if i get off the
plane you said you wouldn't arrest me so
you as the top should have to honor them
you're trying not to arrest no you
should though
you should have to honor that that's my
right we'll talk to the country and tell
them we need to remove it
so that's my fight it's like you need no
we're getting to the point where you're
not expecting
[Applause]
[Music]
no man that's not okay dude
that's not okay you know it's 29th
century
and i was calm and you honestly
acknowledged me for a moment and then
you didn't take your hands there why did
you do that
like that
you didn't have to like that
that's not real man
just grab her bag
yeah she had a green backpack
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
why would i stop when you lie to me
how is anyone gonna stop anything when
you lie to them
you had your chance man
i had my chin you didn't even give me a
kiss i looked at you in your eyes and i
knew you were lying to me
no
no
don't
you can't bullshit sure that's funny
that was the resistance that you felt
no
five times
i saw you outside before i even came in
with your mask off no
you're better than that that's not cool
that's not cool dude it's really hot
it's really not i am not a person
hurting anybody
interference
yes
[Music]
all right
[Music]
you know
watch your head
yeah she's been it's been a lot of talk
i had to pull her off an aircraft so
i don't know how she's gonna act now but
she's been chirping the whole time so
we'll see
how it goes
not with you because you're a liar no he
said he literally the reason he has to
be arrested right now
why is he you you looked at me in my
eyeballs i looked at you outside of the
plane before i ever went in there you
didn't have masks on no can i say
something before anybody takes me out so
that i can just say what i have to say
and then i can say what i have to say
and then that
i i will i will do
what y'all want me to do because i'm
here now
no no
i don't it doesn't matter about that
what matters is that you have been in
just officers that's abusing his power
and you need to know that timothy
timothy hey can
my mother's a social worker and you're
about to like really because i you you
made eye contact with me before i ever
got on that plane you acknowledged the
fact that you weren't wearing a mask
okay
and then you got on the plane and then
you made eye contact with me and then
you've been manipulating the situation
no that's what happened like i'm sorry
that's what happened so
i know the
here let me get your temperature at
least
anybody yeah
oh you think he's cute oh yeah i thought
he was cute too i thought he was cute
too i looked in his eyeballs and i
thought he looked into my eyeballs and
then he
abused that
hello um yeah what's your name
and this is
i should not be arrested right now
[Music]
would you can i have your name please
first can we just adopt something that
makes me want to be safe
why can't i not be safe
stop i would relax if you would let me
you're not michigan
oh my god
you have to leave
my money's in this bank and i'm going to
take it out well then you have to divide
by the rules
and you have to have a mask
it's not
businesses have the right to refuse
service even if you're not winning
that's their choice
awesome well you need to go and get a
mask and then take your money out you're
not allowed to do
ma'am listen we're gonna do this
easy way of the hard way what are you
gonna do arrest me yes for intruding on
premises
that's hilarious that's exactly what it
is yeah
and you believe in this i believe in it
do you believe in this the law is yes
the law says that i do not have to wear
a mask
you can not in public but you're not in
public you're not in public
i'm not going to argue with you about
this this is not a public place this is
a private business no you're not
we're going to go outside
are you serious
do i look like i'm kidding well i don't
know because let's let's go outside and
you've got some issues i've got issues
that you're taking away people's
oh
say you don't stop resisting stop are
you gonna are anybody gonna like get
real here
really relax no one's gonna get real
wow
come on
now you're smashing my arm into my
private area
your private area yeah put your hands
behind your back
my hand is behind my back this one turn
over on your stomach put your hand
behind your back
relax
no you are not relaxed
not relaxed at all
[Music]
wow
[Music]
yeah okay
stand up stand up
stand yourself up
and how do you suggest sir i am like a
65 year old woman here okay
sit down do it
stand up
are you going to need pebbles stand up i
usually make portfolio
are you trying to speak spanish to
people i do speak spanish okay well
stand up
are you happy
i'm not happy okay stand up stand up
come on you know what i think she's
getting your stuff come on
i think you broke my freaking foot okay
i'll call and that's my business over
there yeah she's gonna pick it up
wow
not wearing a mask people
this is what they do to you
what's everybody out there
[Music]
okay um i found my dog in my truck i got
you
i'm 10-4 uh send ems for a 60 year old
white female she's complaining of uh
foot pain yeah
take a seat
49 we're out with them
okay take a seat are you where's your
mouse
where's your feet away from you oh well
i was six feet away from those people
in there get inside come on you guys
let's get real
[Music]
nice and important you probably put
yourself in the position
that's a typical man typical typical man
to say that ma'am no weapons on you or
anything like that no here no no that's
okay stand up for me please no i'll just
make sure you're on your level
i don't know turn around i don't want to
touch your pocket okay
under rush of battery i didn't do any
better no when you spit on people that's
battery no i did not listen he verbally
abuses well that doesn't give you the
right to spit on him that's right you
verbally abused me as soon as i got here
that spit on you you're an arrest for
battery
yeah they're handcuffs they're not for
comfortable can i take my purse
absolutely come on
no no you're definitely going to jail
let's go fuck
unbelievable
can i leave my car here that's
absolutely fine sure
yeah this is unbelievable unbelievable
this is unbelievable let's go
unbelievable unbelievable
well i'll get a good attorney god bless
you yep god bless meet god because i'm a
christian
christians don't talk like you no but
you know what i just went through can i
put that in my purse i need to collect
your property you are a prisoner now i
need to collect your money i've never
been to prison well you are tonight
please
don't know if you're going to jail
please open your hand what is this
that's my cleaner okay so let it go well
can you give me a cleanness
officer please don't just get yeah just
say that they said it desired
prosecution
ago they said no no because they told me
yes
how about you just stand there and stop
talking
how about we do that
how about we do that that doesn't give
you an excuse to act the way that you're
acting
just stop talking
you have to leave we'll take care of it
thank you so much all right
this officer saw me last night i've been
having a lot happening in my
i have friends that are muslim okay
i have friends that are uh
oh that hurts you're hurting my name oh
they're handcuffs they're not for
comfort well i've never had him so
that's a no okay so those those same
muslims that you were talking shit to
just decided your fate and they elected
to not prosecute god bless you yeah god
bless them because if it was up to me
you'd be going to jail
but they decided as a victim that you
were not going to jail oh i suggest you
watch your mouth because
shut up listen the particular group that
you decide to mouth off to were
professional or nice some people might
kick you in your face and they're gonna
come pick up the pieces so i suggest you
watch your mouth this officer saw me
last night he knows i'm not a bad person
i don't think he had to know you i just
thought you were having issues yesterday
because of my uh card my father was with
the army she was the captain did anybody
get her 14th okay look what you did to
me you should be going to jail huh oh
can you get me my purse please hey you
got hey you gotta you got a 14. no i'm
getting no i thought i thought he was
holding it get yourself and leave what
do i do
what do you do and what oh that hurts
that's unfortunate well i've never had
this happen to me then keep your mouth
shut and you won't have it happen again
literally keep your mouth shut because
you spit on somebody
listen you you don't know what he did to
me you don't have the right to ask me
how to talk to you when you're
disrespecting people he disrespected me
first literally spitting on people
gather your belongings count your
blessings and leave
listen i'm bisexual yeah well you need
to look that up and i go to calvary
chapel you need to that's concerning
very concerning yeah we'll talk to
pastor doug i will actually i will talk
to pastor doug and let her know how you
feel about monday different religions
okay for sure okay yeah 11 a.m all right
good night all right good night
thank you officer you have a good night
respectful you're respectful
they all are man
thank god for president trump
[Music]
okay where'd you put it
[Music]
me
let go
[Music]
[Music]
yes
let go of me you're hurting me and i'm
going to show all the bruises that you
should put on me if you're not going to
cooperate you'll be charged
shut up what an asshole thing to say to
me
what what an ass thing to say to me
they're the law enforcer they're always
gonna win that's your turn do me a favor
do me a favor
let go of me you're hurting me i'm not
hurting you you are hurting me
obstruction at the moment
okay
here
ma'am i don't care if you record but can
you just step back a little bit
i can talk in her ear no you need to
just
let go let's walk over and put her in
the car
stop
you're hurting me walk then you're
hurting me damn it
okay you're under arrest right now okay
you are hurting me what
you're hurting me please stand up and
walk then
you're hurting me let go of me
let go of me
oh man you're under arrest for what
obstruction i didn't obstruct anything
you're hurting me
you're hurting me
you're okay
yeah
what are you doing you're hurting me
get out of my pocket you are under
arrest
stay back
back up
unless you want to be detained too back
up i don't care if you record just back
up
stand up straight ma'am
i am standing straight you're pushing me
over with your hand i'm holding on to
your jacket
baby what are you talking about
get out of my pants i am conducting a
search
if you move you will find additional
charges
find additional charges
this is like a rest
without cause
do you really know what you're doing
do you have any ideas
just get over a little bit
do you really know what you're doing
you're assisting merrick garland
to not show the truth away
get over it
i'm gonna let gjpd do what they need to
do with it
do you understand that is not my idea
okay we have this ipad that is not my
ipad that you're saying
someone else's property i hear what
you're saying you've taken my you've
taken all my equipment all my stuff and
you still can't find anything tina i'm
taking this ipad it's because of this
search warrant which lets me do that let
me read the search box that would be
great will i read it
yeah but i can't exactly hold it i will
have bruises to show how they've hurt
you so
you're going to listen to this officer
but if the way he removes handcuffs
that's fine no i'm not you're not being
detained by me you're free to leave but
if you'd like me to explain this to you
i'd rather stand face to face and let
you hold it than have you be in the back
of a cop car is that yeah yeah that's
cool okay that's great with me
can you just sit back a little bit yeah
thank you
step on out up on the sidewalk
and would you like an ambulance
i took a picture of my
to
handsome